>> HARDWICK: First up-- Tom
Brady's got it all!
Four NFL championships, a
supermodel wife, even a cameo in
the film "Ted 2," which is a big
achievement.
The Patriots QB is headed to his
seventh Super Bowl, but SB
Nation reports that when asked
for comment on the refugee
crisis created by the Muslim
ban, Brady replied, quote,
"What's going on in the world?
I haven't paid much attention.
I'm just a positive person."
(laughter and groaning)
(Hardwick laughs nervously)
"Hey, no, please.
Also, when's that big election
everyone's talking about gonna
happen?
What? White privilege?
I've never heard of it.
Anyway..."
(laughter)
Comedians, Tom Brady's obviously
been distracted prepping for
this big footballing game.
Catch him up on the news in one
sentence.
Whitney.
>> So, in football terms, it's
like if Donald Trump was the
quarterback, but instead of
throwing to the receiver, he's
Hitler.
(laughter)
(applause and cheering)
Yeah.
>> HARDWICK: All right, points.
>> Thank you.
>> HARDWICK: Will Sasso.
>> All anyone needs to know is,
we won, you snowflake, libtard
cucks!
We're making America great
again! No?
>> No?
>> HARDWICK: All right.
>> Oh, no, no, not such much.
>> HARDWICK: Okay, yeah, yeah.
>> Not so much here. I'm sorry.
>> HARDWICK: Well done.
>> I'm so sorry. I forgot...
>> Wrong cable network!
>> I'm so sorry.
>> HARDWICK: Yeah, it's wrong.
Paul Scheer.
>> Dude, imagine if Roger
Goodell was the president.
>> HARDWICK: All right, points.
(laughter, applause)